- [Announcer] This UCSD
TV Program is presented
by University of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest programs.
(lighthearted piano music)
We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked, large brain.
Long the master of fire,
tools and language,
but still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly,
we hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from
our shared understanding
of the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insight on who
we are and how we got here.
An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
(energetic piano music)
- It's an especial
privilege for us at ASU,
Arizona State University
to be collaborating
for the first time
officially with our partners
here at CARTA to create this symposium
on evolution of medicine.
I've actually had the privilege
of working with Ajit Varki
on several previous ones on
medicine, one on the origins
of morality and I must say
that all of the efforts you see
from all these different people
and the quite extraordinary
production value, it's not just pretty,
it actually makes the science
better and we can hear
each other clearly and talk to
each other in wonderful ways.
I think it's a wonderful
investment and we thank everyone
who's made it possible.
This field really, in terms
of the new version of it,
began about 25 years ago with
a question and it's a simple
question we all ask
ourselves at times that is,
"Why didn't natural
selection do a better job?".
(audience laughing)
You feel like when you're
sitting with your back pain,
and you think it's your back
pain and you go to your doctor
and say, "Why do I have back pain?".
But, many of us have
been encouraging asking
a different question.
The question is, "Why do almost
all of us have back pain?
Please couldn't we have a better job?".
And then then a kind of
off joke I make sometimes,
"We have figured out what
women want, we really would
like to know why is the birth
canal so narrow, really?".
So many things about the
body seem as if they could
be made better, in a way
that improves health simply,
but for some reason they haven't
Enormous efforts and have
gone in recent decades to try
and understand this whole
different kind of explanation
for disease.
Not why one person gets sick,
not why the mechanism is
broken in that person,
but why the mechanism is
vulnerable to failure in everyone.
We're taking the transition
from a view of the body,
from a mechanics point of view which is,
hey it's broken, what's
broken, let's fix it.
To an engineer's point of
view of asking instead,
"Who designed this thing?
Why isn't it better?
Why can't it be made
better in the future?".
You'll hear marvelous examples of that
in the next few talks.
The last couple decades however,
have vastly expanded the scope.
That question about why
our bodies aren't better,
is only one small part
of evolutionary medicine,
which really includes everything
having to do with the basic
science of evolutionary
biology, being applied to
medicine and public health,
really for the first time.
CARTA has been instrumental in
helping that transition happen.
The medical school here is one of the few
where medical school
students are starting to get
a grounding in evolutionary
biology of the same kind
of grounding that they get
in genetics, physiology,
biochemistry and all of the other sciences
that are equally useful for medicine.
The field that (mumbles)
We have the editor of the
main journal, "Evolution,
Medicine, and Public
Health", with us here today,
Stephen Stearns.
There are societies,
international societies
for evolutionary medicine
and public health,
it's having it's third meeting
in Europe, this August.
There are all kinds of other meetings,
I'll show a slide in my talk briefly later
about how you can find more
information about those.
For right now, I just want to emphasize,
not only how much fun this all is,
but how important it is for us
to have chances to talk to each other.
There will be only a 20 minute break,
but we're going to try to
get you out on time for that.
Do write down your questions,
there's no chance for
questions between these talks,
all the questions will be at the end.
(energetic piano music)